[Music]
so you know how
the infrastructure bill that pat or the
infrastructure bill the an
anti-inflation bill which is going to
cause inflation that just passed
uh hires eighty seven thousand uh
eighty seven thousand more um
irs agents well yeah we need to get that
money well i kind of wanted people to
see what what some of those agents look
like um this is the latest training sesh
for specifically the ones that we saw
the advertisement for you ready these
are the people that are gonna kick your
door down remember they're armed
hold on
and then
and the guy in the wheelchair
bro what a [ __ ] white white pearl
i'll just tip that one over
what do you what do you what do you
think guys
i think we're gonna be [ __ ] we're gonna
be fine so what are they so they're not
agents they're getting irs stormtroopers
yes that is correct and but they all
look like the burger king kids club
their nests don't like the original irs
tax agents that i remember like
it made sense they had a gun they had a
gun they were technically a certain
whatever it is cs level eight or above
they
got
their [ __ ] whatever their clearances
they trained with their firearm they
wore suits i mean they were basically
federal agents right but this looks like
they're just like they're getting their
own little mini
police force people but wait a second
merc you haven't seen him in action
what a crop
right there what a crop
look at that guy guys maybe 19.
guy in the back used to work at the fact
i was at a mexican restaurant not
everybody here look at that look at
these look at these agents look at the
elite ready you ready
all right whenever you guys are ready
here you go
so this is them what you're watching now
is them practicing
raiding a place
you ready
forget about checking the story uh the
the corner
first mistake
yeah he literally went
and then stormed in with a gun yeah you
heard the guy go don't forget to
identify yourself oh yeah irs
oh i didn't i didn't
oh yeah if you did that in the wrong
place you would be dead fat guy would
have already been dead
uh you know it would have been legal
yeah yeah and the person would have been
acquitted too they'd be like they did
not identify themselves we have it on
the security footage i was actually
talking to this dude who was uh who said
it's related to kind of like you said
about identifying yourself this dude who
was over at his father's house his
father
was a retired like hillsborough under
the hillsborough detective right but he
went over to his father's house for his
retirement party and he brought his kids
over and you know and the and the
so uh you know his kids were in the
dad's pool so there was hanging out
whole family thing whatever
and
this guy the hoa guy instead of knocking
on the door this is in florida mind you
hillsboro you know what he did
he unlocked the gate because they're all
in the backyard and walked in the guy's
property
he said his dad out of instinct is a cop
grabbed his gun his gun was on the table
point and he goes free what are you
doing here and that goes i'm so i'm the
hoa guy they just said there was a lot
of noise here and they told me he goes
you can't just walk on people's property
and the cop calmly explained the dad
who's just retired experience do you
understand i could have killed you and i
would have been in my right you cannot
just walk into people's property and he
also brought up number one you didn't
announce yourself number two you just
walked onto my [ __ ] property
and and that's how people get killed and
that's how you see when they raid homes
sometimes and cops get killed and the
guy gets off it's because of not
announcing yourself to be honest
yep
i had a honestly i think your house is
the only one i would ever like
barge into and that would only be if
like there was a plan for me to be there
you know what i mean like if you were
like hey yeah we're hanging out today or
barbecue whatever that's probably the
only place i'd probably just walk into
right of course
i've had dude this is florida you need
to like my buddy um pat had a um
a get-together on memorial day weekend
this year it was all the way in [ __ ]
clearwater he rented a really nice
airbnb whatever but i didn't know that
neighborhood it was parties happening at
several houses when i got on that block
and i'm like it's memorial day weekend
[ __ ] sleepy right so i park and
everything and i go and i like think i
have the right house
and i'm standing and i'm doing the thing
where you're kind of on your tippy toes
trying to look over you know what i mean
right right right and then eventually i
have to call my buddy and i'm like and
he's not picking up and i had to call
another buddy until somebody picked up
to go hey can somebody come out i want
to verify yeah you don't want to walk in
my [ __ ] house because it's florida
dude you'd be lucky if you don't get
[ __ ] shot so well yeah dude you got
to be very careful you can't just go
boom and then come in waving a gun
because you're gonna get shot and then
the second guy's gonna go hey irs and
you're gonna go oh okay and by the way
let's put something this is the thing
here none of us are obviously like
military experts or seal team six people
but let's play this video again from the
beginning and let's see all the things
they did wrong you ready all right could
we get some action music
yes volume yes i could do that
i
some
nice
action music can i make a request sure
the theme from steven seagal's [ __ ]
uh under siege too got it
yep
yep i know exactly that's not but that's
not royalty-free
merch i am seeing it on 57 different
youtubes i think we're gonna be okay all
right oh yeah we don't really care about
this stuff yeah it's a patreon channel
who gives a [ __ ]
um
oh yeah yep good call virtually make
sure it's low enough
okay scott beach just got to be there
for the
ambiance is that a good level
yes okay here we go
i threw out this one as a joke dude and
it was perfect
dead
dead dead dead shot dead
dead uh hey let me ask you a question
guys just real quick
what if somebody comes out of this door
back here right behind you
you know what that hey how about this
what if that what happens if uh the guy
on the right gets startled he's gonna
shoot the person on the left in the back
yes they're teaching them how to raid a
house that's what you know i'm saying
they're teaching them to raid a house in
a single file line nobody is taking any
kind of position they're just they're
doing the [ __ ] they're doing hold on
to be fair they have to be in a single
file that way when jackie chan shows up
he has to fight one they have to attack
him one at a time
you know what the saddest part is virgie
and i
have just based on just playing enough
tarkov
and being jittery enough if they gave us
guns and let us do this without any
practice we would have nailed it way
better than this
we're just used to being paranoid anyway
find a corner that you know you can't
get shot from put your back to it all
right now watch that doorway all right
you clear these doorways go these guys
are coming he's aiming the gun in the
[ __ ] guy
hey put your hands up
you want to know my favorite part
they're clearing the room with their
eyes not the gun they're like looking
around the room but they're always
leaving the gun pointing you're
literally supposed to
aim with your gun into every dark corner
and room and clear it behind every
curtain [ __ ] every closet door he
just is they're just all coming in
pointing forward like this feels like
almost like one of those bad movies
where nobody knows they're like i don't
know just give them guns and they run in
and everybody's aiming them and half of
them are aimed at each other's backs
this is the net 3.0
this is what yes
3.0 and the whole plot is about how
cryptocurrency isn't being taxed enough
where's the ethereum
by the way in case they ever raid you
know an empty warehouse
that's true
all right i'll take your word for it
now i'm going to turn my back to you and
smoke a cigarette
sir
[Applause]
this girl's pointing the gun at the
guy's head in front of her
what are you doing ladies they're all
pointing guns at each other is this a
double cross oh my god
other views in the chat said most tax
evaders hide in marriott lobbies
it's not the lobby it's the conference
room
[Laughter]
hey just want to wrap this up we got a
wedding coming in at 4 30.
[Music]
we're obviously going to play more but
you know you survived to be a study this
is what this is like hold on hold on
this is just like here hold on here
yes we're all going to put down our guns
we'll put down our weaponry on the count
of three okay you ready i'm ready one
two
three
you know i don't mind like the office
isn't all right yeah i hate office
people though
oh you people that are obsessed with it
yes yeah i get it it is like the people
that made it they're one of their
personality traits well it's like the
same people that make weed their
personality you know jesus i don't know
i'm not saying anything sir i'm not irs
special agent how
just like kicking his feet and [ __ ] like
a bored child go back hold back how come
i'm going to ha
how come they don't how come they don't
let the wheelchair guy do the raid
i like that one guy's aiming at his head
and one guy is aiming at his dick
you're gonna have to this is gonna be
the whole [ __ ] this could be like
another 30 minutes of this show but can
you just please go back a little bit
yeah dude i could do a month here i'll
go back this video is going to eat up a
lot of times okay
guys
one's aimed at the head one's aimed at
his dick
you know what i mean they're like look
bro we're gonna [ __ ] you up two ways
from sunday if you don't tell us where
the bitcoin is
so you know what you know what it
reminds me i feel like that there's like
when a partitioning at like high school
and at the other end you're just here
you're hearing this
yes
through the partition you're hearing
that oh yeah cause they're practicing
they're playing basketball on the other
side
[Applause]
every once in a while a ball flies by
boom boom boom
my bad you see some [ __ ] high
schooler and basketball shorts run by
and grab it
i'm a bad guy trying to do live fire
exercises over here
i'm not saying nothing
sir
[ __ ] basketball player comes back and
he just whispers to him he goes like
hey man you're holding the gun wrong you
just send your sleeves
you're about to execute a federal
warrant on behalf of the department of
treasury and those are the genes you
chose
that was our
that was what we chose today with the
little bleach with the little bleach
stripe in the front you know what makes
it funnier not only are we we're hiring
87 000 more of them and we're paying for
it
hey honey i got a raid today we're
taking down a money launderer get my
cool jeans
kids
these [ __ ] are dressed like
hank scorpio
baby you remember the jeans i wore
no not to chris not to the memorial day
thing to bobby's birthday honey honey
honey those are acid washed i don't
think they're in style you sure you want
to wear them
honey they said we could wear jeans they
said it's a new irs
i mean i get it but like they said they
can't afford to pass well enough to wear
suits anymore so we have to wear this
it's kind of like now the post office
has to make the has to make the mail
delivery people drive their own cars
okay first off here's what needs to
happen number one one person needs to be
responsible for doing all the talking
that way there's not confusion that way
there's not people talking over each
other one person becomes responsible for
the talking yeah voice pretend to be a
federal agent for a second okay uh sir
get on the ground irs all right
federal agents
tom under arrest we're executing tom i
have it
tom i got it all right tom i got it you
wanna you i got it
oh okay oh [ __ ] oh they ran away while
we were
oh [ __ ] they're gone oh they're gonna go
oh we're so fired oh
three billion dollar raid oh we're so
fired oh we're so fired no we're not
we're irs agents oh you're right we just
got promoted
get oh see hold on you know what mers
it's okay we have a new assignment we're
rating mar-a-lago
yeah the irs is gonna kick in the doors
yeah they're gonna blow in the doors to
mar-a-lago with a dynamite yeah just
because they're gonna fight they found
out that trump has a gumball machine
there that he's not reporting the income
on yeah
just [ __ ] man how many gumballs have you
sold
oh no
busting down a lemonade stand honestly
we have a gumball guy for that i don't
know i have to tell you all right
well you noticed too they didn't work
out like uh
they didn't get all right if this were
me right
i i'm running an irs field office right
uh-huh i could literally print money if
i just want to just spend money
like they're just going to give me all
the money i want so i could have hired
some good actors to play money
launderers giving them a character and a
script
and then the agents could that guy just
literally said i'm not saying nothing
like 500 times nobody's asked him to say
anything
like it's just like nobody figured out
what the lines were or what the like who
who's the character that we're raiding
what's the basis it was just go in and
wave guns at each other
and play this feels like little kids
playing right
little kids playing pretend for an irs
raid but none of them really know what
the irs does or what taxes are so after
i hire the people merchant i'm with you
i would hire actors but i'll get them
all stanzo brand fedoras i know a guy
that could get us like 50 of them god
these smell terrible you might as well
just hire actors to be the irs agents
because they probably do a [ __ ]
better job at it that's true those
fights are you know what it's true those
those actors are like trained for those
for those movies actually go through
real firearm training you know what i
mean like i was watching like chris
pratt was the doing like showing like
the training was doing for that military
show and he went through actual like you
know like a seal training
will smith is another was an idiot but
we've all seen that video of will smith
even with the prop gun where he actually
respects where he respects guns like
whoa whoa whoa and then he immediately
checks to see if it's loaded
turn around
i have
oh my god everyone's talking over each
other
i'm sorry is this an irs raid or
midnight rift party i i don't know
and then and then it's that it's small
small green going like
my microphone's not that good tonight in
that episode
oh my god he did good good catch fergie
hold on you're right this is going to
take us forever because i have a second
video there's so many things i have a
second video hold on here you go
do you have any other weapons on your
hands nope
he dropped it he dropped the gun
this is and it's by the way those are
prop guns those things are like
weightless yeah
those look like the wooden gun that they
gave wool farrell and the other guys
well they are they're just plastic
they're like little plastic they don't
even the trigger doesn't even pull
they're just gun shaped plastic they
weigh less than an arcade cabinet gun oh
this is amazing
an arcade cabinet gun is the best
description hey listen you i always used
to complain when i play those games and
i'd be like can't they make this a
little like lead's not expensive right
you could put a little lead in this
thing anybody and any of you guys a time
crisis fan
remember that show the show remember
that time crisis
where you had the crisis
i never knew any of the plots to any of
those stupid games you just because they
don't have one stuff yeah you just shoot
at stuff yeah
all right there's never played the one
uh tokyo
911 it's
it's time crisis but you step in and
it's like the [ __ ] old xbox jammy
where it like scans you and then you
just duck around the bullets and [ __ ]
you know what i've never played it
because it reminds me of that tragedy
what
yeah what's the name of the game volde
what's the name of the game
oh yeah it reminds me of that tragedy
so
so like we're in agreement here that
they're not actually training these
people they're just sending them in to
get shot as a pretext for like you know
it kind of feels like the reason we're
hiring 87 000 women because we need
cannon fodder for they need cannon
fodder yeah that's what yeah like they
did their bodies what kind of tax war
are they planning that's a very good
point now
i don't understand it right like like i
have my situation going on right so they
sent me a letter
and then i hired a firm
and then i'm like okay we'll work it out
yeah but not all of them
i don't understand the problem here
you're gonna be dealing with one of
these irs agents pretty soon and then
you're going to be in real trouble but
hold on a second but i'm not going to
because from day one i'm like okay i'm
i'll get in completely like whatever we
got to do yeah but hold on a second
we'll go through this stuff not all of
us make 500 000 a year like you do so we
don't understand like that level of irs
you know
by the way the mist what a huge mistake
they made and then like you know what
they did such a great job it's 87 000
more of them
well good hopefully we get one of them
can re-go over this a little bit
you're looking at them do these guys
look like they're gonna review it yeah
that fat chick's gonna look it over and
go oh i think he meant to say 750 000.
great like they're basically the irs is
doing with me what a teacher used to do
to you with detention yep all right mr
lopez you won't be a [ __ ] funny guy
guess what you got two days of detention
and you're like but this is [ __ ] you
want to make it three huh how about four
days of detention you're like i don't
think you can do that with my income
though
[Music]
she let go of his hands to pull out the
cuffs from her skinny jean pocket oh my
god good eye cause you know it's funny
this video has so many things that i was
looking behind her
at the guys at the fat guy pointing the
gun at the guy in front of his head
again yeah he's just they keep aiming
guns at each other bro this video
there's so many things his fingers on
the trigger that's great yeah um also i
don't know if you just noticed though he
said what am i under arrest for he said
sir you're under arrest for
conspiracy to what
that's what he said he's got not like
it's just there's so much wrong with
this
it's pretty [ __ ] crazy right
this feels like a comedy sketch
[Music]
you notice the way he says that it goes
up at the end considering he intended
there to be conspiracy because it's
usually supposed to be like conspiracy
to commit tax fraud or conspiracy to
launder money or conspiracy it literally
went you're under arrest for a
conspiracy
i don't have a paper with me but i swear
we have a paper
now this is where this video ends and
that's sad except for
i have another video another training
video would you like to see the other
training video
sure
what is this hold on hold on
hold on
is that chick behind him hot
huh
she's hot what is this for the irs
you're under arrest modern irs voice the
chances of it having a penis is like 60
40. fair enough from the jail buddy wait
which way
he goes did you see that little cl
no i got it i know it's a small thing we
literally just said uh you're under
arrest and he's like who are you he's
like well we're with the irs you're
going to jail buddy first of all
you're training maybe don't throw the
little you go into jail buddies in there
secondly how is he in cuffs on his knees
and he's just now identifying who you
are like i would never allow myself to
be handcuffed at gunpoint until somebody
at least identified themselves to me you
know what i mean he's in cuffs on the
ground going who are you and they're
like i alright like you're just asking
that now it dude if somebody kicked my
door in and just said i would just start
shooting at them until somebody's
terrified and then if i saw hey polk
county sheriff's department i'd be like
oh okay i'll put my hands behind my back
now i just wanted to know who was asking
that's all was it the polk county
sheriff's department or just some
teenager from down the street with two
of his buddies
okay
and by the way if i go who are you and
you go with the irs i'll be like you do
not look like mike rotunda
what is this we're the irs
you're under arrest you're going to jail
buddy
you're going to jail buddy most people
don't even know that the irs has
criminal investigators who use their
accounting skills and their authority as
a special irs agent to help solve tax
crimes
that's that sounded like a [ __ ] line
from archer yeah like when they were
talking about like cyril that's the
[ __ ]
law enforcement investigators that use
their skills in accounting
[ __ ] what
we are the only agency that can
work investigations regarding tax
evasion
and other tax related offenses the
adrian project has been helping
advertise the irs special agent's ci's
roles for the past 15 years by visiting
different schools around the nation it
was named after adrian university
because that was the first place it took
it happened at they were a public
information officer what's up with this
guy
you know who he reminds me of royce
do you remember the autism reporter from
the onion yes yes
yes that is exactly where the trains
okay
are the trains yeah the trains are fine
in detroit michigan
who
came up with this
this is only the second time this
project has taken place
it was really good it took four minutes
and 35 seconds it was very good we
talked about the irs it was very good
you should have if you have an
accounting
degree
that's the best one though oh my god so
we're just like i'm trapped every day in
the same routine
yeah they make me get up every day in
the morning and then i have to do a
bunch of work in the same order every
day uh-huh yeah and then they just fold
laundry for hours and he's like uh-huh
how do i get in here
he starts rocking back and forth too
yeah
when he gets excited
oh look well there you go guys you ready
look at that look at that elite task
force
i mean you're gonna really lead with the
wheelchair
i mean
you have to lead it with the wheelchair
guys somebody has to push him no but
here's the deal
the only thing they used him for was
that picture yep he watched the video he
wasn't in it for the most part yep
hear me out on this
i'm all for bringing a wheelchair guy on
a team that's going to execute a raid
like this
however
the rule should be
that you should use the wheelchair guy
as the battering ramp i like that
you know what i mean because people have
to push him anyway
you mount a battering ram to his chest
and then that way you can just sort of
have two people just
ramming him into the door
the all the other thing is though i only
want a wheelchair guy on my team if he
could like read minds
you know
okay something like that but i mean i
don't know man this is this is this is
[ __ ] hilarious i mean it's sad
because it's our money and it sucks but
it's also hilarious we're just throwing
money at thinking it's going to help and
you saw the new york post
an agent leaked because leaks come out
of the fbi too saying
come out of the irs too saying this is
100 to target middle class because
confidential internal memos came out
that this that this this hole we're not
going to go after middle-class people
that's 100 now it's already confirmed
now from an fbi an irs leaker that that
is who they are going after
of course
the number of people alone that they
hired is just obvious
they hired more agents than there are
middle class people left in this goddamn
country
they really hate the middle class i
don't know man
they really they're trying to wipe
they've been on [ __ ] top of the
target list for years